>> ♪ ♪
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP DEMANDED
NANCY PELOSI AND ADAM SCHIFF BE
THROWN OUT OF OFFICE FOR THEIR
HANDLING OF THE UKRAINE
WHISTLEBLOWER.
THAT'S HAPPENING WHILE A SECOND
WHISTLEBLOWER CLAIMS TO HAVE
FIRSTHAND KNOWLEDGE OF THE
ALLEGATIONS.
HERE'S THE PRESIDENT MOMENTS
AGO.
>> THE IMPEACHMENT INQUIRY IS A
SCAM.
THE CONVERSATION I HAD WITH THE
UKRANIAN PRESIDENT ZELENSKI WAS
A VERY CORDIAL, GOOD
CONVERSATION.
THE MISTAKE THEY MADE, THE
OPPONENTS, THE DEMOCRATS, THE
RADICAL LEFT, DEEP STATE,
WHATEVER YOU WANT TO CALL THEM.
THEY CAME OUT WITH A WHISTLE
BLOWER REPORT BEFORE THEY SAW
THE CONVERSATION.
THEY WAITED ONE DAY NANCY PELOSI
WOULD NOT HAVE MADE A FOOL OUT
OF HERSELF.
HE DEFRAUDED THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
AND THE CONGRESS AND HIS FAMILY.
IT WAS A HORRIBLE SPEECH.
I THINK HE IS HAVING A BREAK
DOWN.
>> THE PRESIDENT SPEAKING IN THE
ROOSEVELT ROOM.
JESSE, WHERE ARE WE TODAY ON
IMPEACHMENT AND KEEPING TRACK OF
ALL OF THE TWISTS AND TURNS?
>> THEY ARE TRYING TO IMPEACH
THE PRESIDENT IN PRIVATE.
DOING THIS BEHIND CLOSED DOORS.
THEY DON'T LEAD REPUBLICANS
SUBPOENA OR CROSS-EXAMINE AND
THEY WON'T PUT IT TO A FLOOR
VOTE.
AND THE WHISTLEBLOWER LIED WHEN
HE FILLED OUT THE COMPLAINT:
DID YOU HAVE IF I CONTACT WITH
CONGRESS?
WE KNOW ADAM SCHIFF LIED.
HIS TEAM HAD CONTACT WITH THE
WHISTLEBLOWER.
HE LIED TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
AND WITH HELD THAT FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
WHAT ARE THEY HIDING?
THESE ARE THE SAME PEOPLE WHO
INVESTIGATED THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN
USING SECRET WARRANTS AND
FOREIGN POWERS.
OVER THE WEEKEND I DID A DEEP
DIVE AND WE KNOW THAT JOE BIDEN
LIED TWICE ABOUT TALKING TO HIS
SON ABOUT HIS BUSINESS DEALINGS.
THE PICTURE LOOK AT THE
PHOTOGRAPH WITH DEVON ARCHER, HE
VISITED THE OBAMA WHITE HOUSE AT
LEAST TWICE.
I WOULD LIKE TON WHAT HE TALKED
ABOUT THERE.
WHEN THE OBAMA-BIDEN PEOPLE
INSTALLED THEIR HAND PICKED
INVESTIGATORS IN UKRAINE AFTER
THE REVOLUTION, THEY PRESSURED
UKRAINE TO INVESTIGATE PAUL
MANAFORT.
THE DNC PAID ONE OF THEIR
CONTRACTORS $70,000 TO WORK WITH
THE UKRAINE EMBASSY TO GET DIRT
ON MANAFORT.
WHO DID THEY LINK THAT DEEP
STATE DIRT TO?
MICHAELISAKOF FROM THE FAKE
DOSSIER.
AND THE "WALL STREET JOURNAL"
HAS A RUN DOWN ON THE CLINTON
FOUNDATION.
UKRAINE GAVE THE MOST DONATIONS.
$10 MILLION.
THERE IS A LOT OF STUFF WE ARE
LOOKING AT.
THAT'S WHY THE DEMOCRATS ARE SO
NERVOUS.
TRUMP IS DIALING IN ON THE
CORRUPTION AND THE COLLUSION OF
THE LAST ADMINISTRATION.
>> BOSNIA $1 MILLION.
WHAT WAS THAT FOR.
JUAN, LISTEN TO AN MSNBC GUEST.
SHE HAS THIS WHOLE IDEA OF HOW
TO IMPEACH.
WATCH.
>> YOU COULD IMPEACH PENCE
FIRST.
THE PROBLEM IS THAT DONALD TRUMP
THEN HAS TO NAME HIS
REPLACEMENT.
I THINK THAT MAYBE A DEAL COULD
BE STRUCK IF HE WAS TOLD IF YOU
DON'T MAKE A REPLACEMENT THEN
NANCY PELOSI BECOMES PRESIDENT.
YOU WILL BE IMPEACHED AND
CONVICTED.
YOU NEED TO MAKE THIS
REPLACEMENT SO THE PROPER PARTY
REMAINS IN POWER.
>> JUAN, IS THAT A SERIOUS
CONSIDERATION OR JUST KILLER?
>> I THINK THE LATTER.
[LAUGHING].
THAT'S ALL FANTASY.
IT'S THE CASE THAT THE SPEAKER
OF THE HOUSE IS THE THIRD IN
LINE TO BE PRESIDENT.
IF YOU IMPEACH BOTH THE
PRESIDENT AND VICE-PRESIDENT,
BUT THAT'S ALL SILLINESS.
>> HER NAME IS WINEBANKS.
DO YOU THINK SHE HIT ONE?
>> [LAUGHING].
>> I WOULD LIKE TO HAVE AN
ACCOUNT THERE.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> THE THING IS THAT IN FACT
VICE-PRESIDENT PENCE AND HIS
AIDS ARE BEING SUBPOENAED.
THEY ARE AN IMPEACHMENT TARGET.
ANOTHER FANTASY, DANA, IS
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAYING SCHIFF
AND PELOSI SHOULD IMPEACHED.
WINEBANKS IS ON TV FILLING TIME
BUT HE IS THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES SAYING SOMETHING
IMPOSSIBLE.
YOU CAN'T IMPEACH THE SPEAKER OR
A MEMBER OF THE HOUSE.
THAT'S NOT THE WAY OUR POLITICAL
SYSTEM WORKS.
WHAT IS REAL IS THERE IS A
SECOND WHISTLEBLOWER WITH
FIRSTHAND KNOWLEDGE OF WHAT TOOK
PLACE.
WHAT IS REAL IS THAT TRUMP IS
THROWING HIS ENERGY SECRETARY
RICK PERRY UNDER THE BUS SAYING
PERRY TOLD ME TO MAKE THIS CALL.
UNBELIEVABLE.
WHAT IS REAL THERE WAS NO
ADMINISTRATION OFFICIAL ON ANY
OF THE SUNDAY SHOWS NOT WILLING
TO GO OUT THERE.
>> SOMETIMES YOU GIVE THE SUNDAY
SHOWS A BREAK.
>> I THINK THEY ARE IN THE
MIDDLE OF TRYING TO FIGHT THIS
THING.
THE OTHER THING THAT IS VERY
REAL YOU HAVE PEOPLE LIKE ANDY
CARR, GEORGE H.W. BUSH'S CHIEF
OF STAFF SAYING LET'S HAVE AN
INQUIRY AND COLIN POWELL SAYING
REPUBLICANS NEED TO GET A GRIP!
YOU CAN'T LET THIS SLIDE.
>> CAN I PLAY THIS?
SOMEBODY ELSE THINKS REPUBLICANS
NEED TO GET A GRIP OR A SPINE.
HERE'S MAXINE WATERS ON
REPUBLICAN SENATORS AND WHAT SHE
THINKS ABOUT THEM.
>> I AM DISGUSTED WITH THOSE
SPINELESS MEMBERS OF THE SENATE
WHO DON'T HAVE THE GUTS TO STAND
UP FOR THIS COUNTRY.
MANY OF THEM HAVE DEFINED
THEMSELVES AS PATRIOTIC.
THEY ARE SPINELESS.
THEY ARE NOT WILLING TO STEP UP.
>> THIS IS BECOMING A DRUM BEAT
FROM THE LEFT AGAINST THE RIGHT.
>> HERE'S MY QUACKY IDEA.
THIS IS WHY YOU DON'T PUT PEOPLE
FROM THE ADMINISTRATION ON THE
SUNDAY TALK SHOWS.
THESE VOICES ARE HOW DIDDER.
-- LOUDER.
THEY SOUND FROM OUT IN SPACE.
IT'S OFF THE CHARTS CRAZY-TOWN.
QUOTING THE QUEEN OF HEARTS FROM
ALICE IN WONDERLAND.
NO, SENTENCE FIRST AND VERDICT
AFTERWARD.
THE IDEA OF HAVING THE SENTENCE
FIRST.
THAT'S WHERE WE ARE WITH THESE
DEMOCRATS.
IMPEACHMENT AND THE REMOVAL OF A
PRESIDENT BY DECREE WITH THE TWO
HEARINGS SO FAR THAT THE
DEMOCRATS HAD WERE A SECURED
FACILITY.
THIS IS WHY PEOPLE -- THE MORE
YOU HIGHLIGHT THIS CRAZINESS AND
THE MORE THAT YOU TRY TO SOUND
REASONABLE AND SOUND, THAT'S
WHERE THE REPUBLICANS WILL WIN.
>> THERE WAS, GREG, A FORMER
OBAMA OFFICIAL.
MR. BRENNAN, TALKING ABOUT ALL
OF THIS AS WELL.
DO WE HAVE THAT FOR GREG TO
REACT TO?
>> WE LOOK AT THIS AS A VERY
CORRUPT GOVERNMENT UNDER THE
SWAY OF THIS POWERFUL INDIVIDUAL
WHO HAS BEEN ABLE TO JUST
CORRUPT THE INSTITUTIONS AND THE
LAWS OF THAT COUNTRY.
>> WHAT ABOUT THE DEMOCRACY?
>> I THINK IT'S NO LONGER A DIF
AN AUTO-CRAT HAS IT IN HIS
HANDS.
>> NO!
>> WHAT IS GOING ON?
>> STILL INTERVIEWING JOHN
BRENNAN AFTER 3 YEARS OF
HUMILIATING HIMSELF AND BEING
WRONG ON JUST ABOUT EVERYTHING.
THE MEDIA REMIND ME OF THAT GUY
ON THE CARNIVAL.
THEY ARE BREAKING THEIR BACKS ON
THIS STORY.
THE REASON IS FOR THE PAST 8
YEARS BEFORE TRUMP, THEY WERE
LIKE AN ABSTINENT PRIEST AND NOW
THEY ARE IN THE RED LIGHT
DISTRICT AND CAN'T GET ENOUGH.
I AM SICK OF THE TERM
WHISTLEBLOWERS.
THEY ARE WHISTLE ANSWERS.
THE ESTABLISHMENT IS SUPPORTING
THEM.
THEY ARE NOT TAKING ANY RISKS.
GETTING PATS ON THE BACK.
THE IDEA THAT THESE ARE
LEGITIMATE WHISTLEBLOWER.
NO IT'S A LINE OF PEOPLE THEY
HAVE TO SEE WHICH ONE WORKS.
YOU KNOW THE STORE IS WANING
WHEN IT'S GETTING FUN.
THE MEDIA IS NO LONGER COVERING
IMPEACHMENT.
THEY ARE COVERING DEMOCRACY
CONTINUE TO APPLY PRESSURE ON
IMPEACHMENT.
IT'S LIKE SAYING I AM APPLYING
PRESSURE TO KEEP A HORSE IN MY
APARTMENT.
IT WON'T HAPPEN.
THEY ARE STILL ON THE CAROUSEL
PLAYGROUND TO KEEP THE STORY
GOING AROUND AND AROUND.
THEY KEEP INTERVIEWING THE SAME
GUESTS WHO KEEP SAYING THE SAME
THING.
GOING AROUND AND AROUND.
EVERY WEEK THE SAME OLD CRAP.
BUT THE MEDIA IS ASKING YOU TO
JUMP ON.
THEY ARE PROPELLING THE STORY.
>> AND A SECOND WHISTLEBLOWER
REMIND ME OF THE SECOND
KAVANAUGH ACCUSER.
YOU JUST PILE ON.
>> I THINK I WILL BE A
WHISTLEBLOWER.
>> GO INTO HIDING?
>> YES, GO INTO HIDING.
>> YOU NEVER HAVE TO LEAVE YOUR
APARTMENT AND YOU COULD HAVE A
HORSE THERE.
>> A TINY LITTLE PONY.